[MUSIC PLAYING]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Houston, we have a problem.
- Find Professor Langdon.
- Either you're somebody,
or you're nobody.
- So I'm going to turn
around with a great smile,
and walk my white ass
back across 8 mile.
- Trigger that alarm, and
I'll blow your head off.
Stop screwing with me.
- Woo, might make
your head blow off.
- Was it good for you?
- I've had better.
- Awesome.
- Self-sustained civilization
on Mars will be the greatest
adventure.
- I mean, the stuff
has been really wild.
- Ooga, booga!
- If you decide to accept that,
you will seriously fly, son.
- Don't forget to
thank me, baby.
Don't forget to
thank your Cookie.
- What power?
- This power.
- Whose power?
- Our power.
- You're in the middle of a war.
One that's been
going on forever.
- What are you talking about?
- You asked what would
be worth killing for.
Witness the biggest
cover-up in human history.
- I can't get involved in
these people's problems.
- I don't think they're
going to make it
if they're not together.
- To help arm our
agents, so that
they have a fighting chance
against the submachine guns
of some the most
dangerous characters
in the history of
American criminality.
- Stop saying that.
You're not my son.
- It's a bigger idea
than just the concert.
We all have the same struggles.
- Ladies and gentlemen,
here are the Beatles.
- Thank you so much for
believing in my weirdness.
- Clear eyes, full
hearts, can't lose.
- How big is the universe?
- Infinite.
- How do you know for sure?
- I don't.
I just believe it.
- It's the same
with love, I guess.
- Gentlemen, it's been a
privilege flying with you.
- I'm saying that when
the president when
the president does it, that
means it's not illegal.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: Quite a reel.
Thank you, Brian.
I really appreciate
you being here.
Let's start from the early
days, if that's OK with you.
BRIAN GRAZER: Sure.
Sure.
SPEAKER 1: It's good?
You grew up just on the
other side of the hill,
in the valley.
And it all kind of
started, the way
you put it, with
your grandmother.
This little Jewish
woman, named Sonya,
who believed in you,
despite you not doing well
in school, and you kind
of struggling as a kid.
Can you talk about
what she meant to you?
BRIAN GRAZER: What
she meant to me?
Well, she was the single person
that would support me or give
me human, personal validation.
But I think she spotted such
desperation in me that it was
attractive to her, in a way.
Because she would always tell
me, I'm going to be special.
You're going all the way.
And I'm thinking, I'm
going all the way, where?
Where am I going all the way to?
Because she would look
at these report cards,
and there were
always all Ds and Fs.
And so there was
really no evidence
to support what she was saying.
But it was very important
to have one person that
consistently believed in me
and then isolated this one
trait that she thought I
could do, and was doing,
even though it wasn't
as refined as it
is now, which was to use
the power of curiosity
to learn interactively
with people.
And then, of course,
I've taken it
to some other level, where I
have curiosity conversations
every two weeks.
I have for at least 30 years,
every two weeks, faithfully.
And in these curiosity
conversations,
it's just science, medicine,
politics, religion, technology.
I've met a lot of people
in your business, some
of the progenitors of things
that are very important,
some of the founders
of the companies,
particularly yours, in fact.
And so it's been
really edifying.
And I've found ways, through
these curiosity conversations,
to learn different perspectives.
And that's something
you don't do with AI.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, and how
you got started in film
seems very serendipitous.
You were hearing these guys
literally having a conversation
out your window about an easy
job opening at Warner Bros.
When you were a kid, you
weren't dead set on film.
Did you want to
do something else?
BRIAN GRAZER: Well, I assigned
myself to do something else.
But I don't know if I wanted to.
I was going to law school.
I went to USC, and
then I was going
to go to USC law school,
which I got accepted to.
But I didn't really think
that I'd pass the bar.
So I didn't think I'd pass
the bar, if I broke it down,
even making it through
the first year.
But I thought, well,
this is a direction.
It's a choice.
So I'll take this choice.
But it was within the
first week of the summer,
I overheard in my
apartment complex--
actually very close to
here-- on Ocean Avenue.
What was it?
Ocean Avenue, it was
right across the street
from this little
elementary school.
But Ocean and like
5th or something.
And I overhear these two
guys going, oh, my God.
This was the easiest job.
It was so cushy.
I thought, cushy?
It really grabbed me.
I had never heard
the word cushy.
The guy said, yeah,
I had a company car.
Really, at 40 hours
a week I'd get paid,
but there really
wasn't much to do.
And then, I'm listening
in even closer.
And I pull the drapes closed
in my little apartment
and open the window further,
so I could make sure
that I really was
listening and could
hear what they were saying.
They said, oh yeah,
it was at Warner Bros.
From someone named
Peter Connect.
Peter Connect was--
I didn't know--
the head of Warner
Bros. legal department.
So the conversation ends.
And I just immediately
dial 4-1-1.
I get a hold of the
number of Warner Bros.
Pictures.
I ask for Peter Connect.
And I said, I understand
that you might
need a law clerk this summer.
And can I please come in
and interview for the job?
Of course, he did,
because I just heard it.
So now, all of a
sudden, I'm meeting
with Peter Connect at 3
o'clock and getting the job
to work at Warner
Brothers like at 3:15.
So now, I had a job.
And it happened to be in
alignment with the path
of going to law school.
And really, what the job was,
it was kind of a bullshit job.
Those guys were right.
It was kind of a bullshit
job, where you just
sat in a little, teeny
office, about like this big.
And it was with no
windows, a little desk,
and you'd wait to either
file papers or deliver papers
to somebody for Warner Bros.
So a couple of weeks go in,
I do have a company car,
all that stuff.
All those things were true
about how cushy it was.
And I have to deliver papers
to, ironically, Warren Beatty.
Warren Beatty was huge.
You know, this was a while ago.
He was a gigantic movie
star, like as big a movie
star as you could get.
But he was also a star,
and he was a writer,
and he was a director.
And I think he'd already done
shampoo, if I'm not wrong.
And I didn't even have
to deliver these papers.
He lives at the
Beverly Wilshire Hotel.
So I go to the Beverly
Wilshire Hotel,
and I'm waiting at the desk.
And one of his assistants
comes down and says,
hand me the papers, kid.
And so I just think
to say, well, I
can't hand you the papers.
I have to hand them
directly to Mr. Beatty.
And the guy goes--
like a version of
you're full of shit--
just hand me the papers.
I said, these papers are invalid
unless I hand them directly
to Mr. Beatty.
And I said it with
enough conviction
and repeatedly
that they said, OK.
OK.
And so then I'm intercepted
by another assistant,
like the higher level assistant.
I say the same thing
and persuade him.
He said, OK.
Just hand him the papers,
and then you leave.
I go up there, and the
minute I hand him the papers,
I generate a connection.
And I turn that little moment
into an hour conversation
with Warren Beatty, which was
really, really informational.
It was amazing.
And I just got a lot out of it.
And also, I got confidence from
doing it, for having him say,
yes.
SPEAKER 1: How did you have
that kind of healthy sense
of entitlement or chutzpah--
you know, you're
23-year-old legal clerk--
to be in the presence
of Warren Beatty
and have his ear for an hour?
BRIAN GRAZER: Well,
how did I get that?
Well, I got it from
my grandmother.
My grandmother
helped that a lot.
Chutzpah.
I think I've always been into
disrupting my comfort zone.
And I do it professionally.
And it's really an additive.
I know that you guys
had Simon Sinek.
He did a Google
Talk for you guys.
He has two of the top five
TED Talks in the world.
And one of them is on the why--
why you do what you do.
Now, he diagnosed me, because
I got to be friends with him.
And he said my why was--
because he asked me-- what
was the most important moment
in your childhood
school-life experience?
And I explain it.
Then he connects all these dots.
And at the very end, he goes--
and I've known him now
a couple of years--
I think you think your why is
curiosity, but that's your how.
Your why is you hate
bullies, which I just
learned like two weeks ago,
which really came together
for me.
Because I really
do hate bullies.
And so I think that
was part of it.
Whether it's a bully or
just a man in general,
I wouldn't say I'm
defiant against it.
I'm just cool with it.
I'm cool with going
up against it.
I'm very happy
being the underdog.
In fact, I'm not happy
being beyond that, actually.
And that's why I probably have
made and produced, I think,
100 movies and seven or eight
really important television
shows.
And they're all startups.
And I think I like startups.
I like having an idea,
building it out of zero,
and then case building it to
the point that it has value.
And once I do that to the point
that that gas becomes a solid,
then I like to start
on another one.
That was a long answer.
SPEAKER 1: That
was a great answer.
Warren Beatty was just
the tip of the iceberg.
You spoke to Lew
Wasserman and Mel Brooks.
Am I right about that?
BRIAN GRAZER: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: And it seems
like you kind of understood.
You had this fundamental
understanding
that your career was going to
be made on relationships and not
on a direct rise
through the meritocracy.
How did you have that
understanding so young?
BRIAN GRAZER: Well, OK.
That's cool.
Well, just one differentiation--
look, relationships are
extremely important.
But I think insight
is more important.
And what I gained out
of these conversations
that I'd have with Warren
Beatty or you know-- what I did
is I quit going to law school.
Let's see if we
can capture this.
But I quit going to
law school, because I
saw that this was a method that
would be pretty awesome for me.
And I say to my
boss, Peter Connect,
I'm just going to stay here.
But I did happen to
notice way down the hall
there was that vacant office.
This office was
twice as big as his.
But he didn't care, because
he started with Jack Warner
like a zillion years ago.
And so he just goes,
I'll get it for you.
He gets me this giant office,
the size of this room.
But really, with two
union secretaries there.
So now, I have this
amazing, big office.
And I can use this for
the Brian Grazer business,
even though I'm working there
and still making my $5 an hour.
So once I got this big
office, and I extended
for an additional year,
then every single day,
whether I was delivering
papers or not,
I was using a similar speech.
I'd say, hi, my name
is Brian Grazer.
I work at Warner Bros.
business affairs.
I kind of fudged
that a little bit.
And I know everything
about your boss.
I would love to have a
conversation with them.
It will last only five minutes.
And I absolutely
do not want a job.
So I do that every single
day, so that every single day,
I could meet someone
that was really
making a difference in the
entertainment business.
It could be
television or movies.
So it wasn't that I counted
on the relationship.
It was more about a
demystification of how
this whole system worked.
Ultimately, what I was able
to learn, even very young,
was how leverage
got created and used
as a tool in our in
entertainment business.
So I kind of stayed, doing that
for about a year and a half.
And just before I got
the boot, because I
kept using their Warner
Bros. assets for me,
I got this one
big meeting with--
who I really wanted to
meet was Lew Wasserman.
Lew Wasserman was like the Don
of the modern entertainment
business.
The most powerful, mythic man
in the entertainment business,
he was really the
founder of MCA Universal.
And literally, everything in
the entertainment business
revolved around Lew Wasserman.
So I find a way to
meet Lew Wasserman.
And I'm already sort
of trying to have
a conversation with him.
And he sort of puts his
hands up in the air.
And he says, just wait a second.
You're not coming
into my office.
And I thought, well,
like everybody,
I was going into his office.
But no go.
So he comes back with a
legal tab and a pencil.
And he said, take these.
So I take them.
And he says put the
pencil to the paper,
and it has greater value than
it did as separate parts.
Now, get out of here, which
was kind of embarrassing.
But what I realized was he was
saying that you don't really
have anything.
You might have a gift to
get into people's office
and to turn and
create a conversation,
but you don't own anything.
So I realized I better put
the pencil to the paper
and start writing ideas.
And I kind of industrialized
the idea of business.
And I would, every
day, have many ideas
and send them registered
mail to myself.
And I ended up with a
box of hundreds of ideas,
including the one
called Splash--
that was a man falling
in love with a mermaid,
starring Tom Hanks--
and many others.
But I realized that unless you
can codify or write original
ideas and prove that
they are valuable--
you have to make them valuable--
you don't have anything.
SPEAKER 1: I want to talk about
idea generation for a second.
I imagine curiosity
conversations probably
play into different ideas.
And you've talked
about how they've even
turned into movies.
Do you have any other
kind of processes
to help spur creativity
and come up with ideas?
BRIAN GRAZER: Do I have other
ways to spur creativity?
Well, I read.
But I don't really read fiction.
I mean, the first 15 years
of my being a producer,
I just did comedies.
Comedies are fiction.
Well, I don't know.
Whatever you think they are.
They're kind of a combination.
I like the curiosity
conversations,
because I just know that
knowing your inner truth--
whatever that is-- and really
diagnosing what that is--
so you're not
bullshitting yourself--
I know the inner truth that once
you start to understand that
and it's schematic, that
is a way to build ideas.
The movie "Friday Night
Lights" was about me.
It was really just
because I got cut
in a very humiliating way
from high school football,
from Coach Ogawa.
He cut me in front
of like 250 kids.
And the pain of
that was so awesome.
I mean, it was so
memorable to me
that I was able to sort of
think it through and go--
when he pointed to Richard
Cox, over there, and he said
he was quarterback.
And he said to Perry
Shellmyer, you're nose guard.
And he said to Brian
Grazer, your status?
And I said, tailback.
He said, incorrect.
Cut.
I was no longer a human
being in that moment.
And I was able to
sort of catalog that
and many other experiences.
But that one in
particular, I realized
that that lived inside this book
called "Friday Night Lights."
Because anything you read
has multiple interpretations,
right?
SPEAKER 1: I want to skip ahead,
chronologically, a little bit.
You're in the '80s.
You're working at Paramount.
And you want to meet Ron Howard.
He had done "The
Andy Griffith Show."
He'd done "Happy Days."
It almost seems like you knew
you wanted to partner with him
before you met him.
What about him made you
say, this is the guy.
This is the guy I want to work
with for the rest of my life.
BRIAN GRAZER: Well, I didn't.
I actually didn't know.
I just had this quota of
meeting a new person every day.
So I saw Ron Howard
out of my office.
And I yelled out
at him like, hey!
You know, like that.
And he didn't know who I was.
And I scared him.
Then I called his office and
said, I got to meet with you.
I found a way.
Because you can get in,
if you really work at it.
If you're resourceful,
and polite,
you can get people
to meet with you.
But then, when he
walked into my office,
he had this sort of
aura of goodness.
Or it was perceptible to
me that, energetically, he
had goodness about him.
I'm sure you guys feel
stuff like that, right?
You know, you feel like
that person's a bad vibe.
I don't think I want
to be around that.
So it's a very
important metric to me,
how I feel, energetically,
towards somebody.
Because I can think about it.
You feel it, that truth,
and then I often just
think, how will this end?
And if you build
that out, and you
feel like, I think this will end
bad, then you shouldn't start.
But with Ron, I felt like he
just had this aura of goodness
about him.
It was kind of biblical for me.
Of course, I was looking
for that, probably.
I didn't know he
could actually direct.
I had no idea he could direct.
I just liked him
and thought I should
support a guy that seemed good.
SPEAKER 1: Seemed
like it worked out.
BRIAN GRAZER: It did.
It worked out.
SPEAKER 1: Can you
give us a story
of the making of a movie that
seemed very unlikely that it
would be made at the start,
and you kind of willed it
into fruition?
BRIAN GRAZER: I've
had a lot of them.
The first one was "Splash."
Because I had hundreds of
rejections over the course of
like five years.
Just every person
rejected it, repeatedly--
every studio, every buyer--
which caused me to get tough
and become durable, that way.
And I think what I
learned was "Splash,"
even though it was a
man falling in love
with a mermaid, its inner
theme, its interior theme
was about love.
And I realized in retrospect
that people, through the script
or through my pitch,
couldn't see that.
Or they just didn't like it.
I don't know.
But I think if you
can pitch a theme--
if you have a story, but
you know the interior theme,
and you case build
to sell your theme,
themes are often irrefutable.
But I just didn't
know that, then.
So I had hundreds and
hundreds of rejections.
I finally got it made.
It was brutal.
And then, the movie that
models this best for me
was this movie called
"American Gangster."
I don't know if
you ever saw that,
with Russell Crowe
and Denzel Washington.
But it was many, many
years later after splash.
And the studio decided
they were going
to fire the director,
just months before we
were starting to shoot.
And we already had Russell
Crowe in the movie.
Sorry, Denzel
Washington in the movie.
We didn't have Russell Crowe.
We had a director.
We'd already spent $32 million.
But they just felt like
this director scares them.
They've thought about it a lot.
He scares them.
It's going to be a bigger
loss if they actually
make the movie.
They'd rather just
write down $32 million.
And that's really
a lot of money.
Even today, it's a lot of money.
But then, it was crazy.
That was like 12 years ago.
That's how scared
they were of this guy.
And anyways, I was able to
immediately recontextualize
it and get better actors
and a much better director.
So I forced them, after
they took the write down,
to talk to me again about
"American Gangster," which
they didn't want to do.
They said, we'll
take the write down,
but don't ever say American
or gangster to us, ever again.
SPEAKER 1: I love the story
of how you got "8 Mile" made.
Can you talk about
that a little bit--
how you met Eminem and slowly
convinced him to do it?
BRIAN GRAZER: Well, yeah.
Very quickly, you said,
how do I get ideas?
I get ideas just by--
it sounds so simple--
trying to be as
present as possible.
So I happened to be in
a taxicab in New York.
And as the guy's weaving
around and everything,
I'm listening to this
faint conversation going on
in the taxicab, on the radio--
a local Manhattan radio.
And ODB, Old Dirty Bastard,
is being interviewed
by some talk show guy.
And you can't even
understand him.
He barely makes any sense.
It's just hard to
really understand him.
But I thought,
what kind of a guy
wants to be called
Old Dirty Bastard?
I mean, that was his
choice to be called that.
I thought, that's an
interesting choice.
So I think, I better
go meet this ODB.
So this is like 25
or 23 years ago.
So I go meet ODB,
and he was a trip.
He wouldn't let me
into his studio.
And everything was a
cost a la carte thing.
If you want to go in the
studio, it's going to cost this.
If you want to do that--
so I just think, wow.
This guy's so interesting.
He's funny and also kind
of scary at the same time.
So after I met
ODB, then I thought
I'd meet this character,
Slick Rick, that
wears a patch on his eye.
He's a rapper.
He's really kind of a
comical British dude.
And then I go through
the series of Chuck D,
et cetera, et cetera.
And I'm thinking, wow,
this is like a movement.
East Coast hip hop
is like a movement.
It can be funny.
It could be the voice
of the inner city.
It's a lot of things.
SPEAKER 1: Did you listen
to a lot of '90s hip hop
at the time?
BRIAN GRAZER: Not really.
No.
No, that isn't what
got me into it.
No, I didn't listen to 90s
hip hop before I met ODB.
It was just a funny name
and a guy wanting to go,
you call me ODB.
Being insistent upon it, that
made me want to go see him.
I didn't know about
the Wu-tang Clan.
And so then, no, I didn't
know anything about it.
And then, because I was still
doing curiosity conversations--
I had started them--
I met with Frank Rich, who
was the editor of the New York
Times.
He was a very, very shishi guy.
We were talking about something
very high faluting, probably
Broadway musicals and stuff,
which he's quite an expert at.
And I say something about
hip hop, and he goes, oh.
He treated it as an
inferior subculture,
like it was less than.
And I thought, I don't
think it's less than.
I think this is the culture,
not a subculture, much
less an inferior subculture.
And I kind of thought I'd build
a story to prove him wrong.
And that's where it
sort of came about.
Then I found a way.
I didn't know who
should be in it.
I've spent years trying
to figure it out.
I tried to get
Spike Lee to do it.
And he was cool, but no go.
And then I was just watching
the VMAs, and I see the camera.
This is like seven or eight
years after the Frank Rich
conversation, or seven
years, and the camera
comes across the audience.
And it's on Eminem, on his face.
And I didn't know who he was.
But he had this sort
of icy, steel glare.
Then, all of a
sudden, he started
laughing or being really fluid.
And I thought, wow, what a
lot of range that dude has.
He could be that, then that.
So then, I wanted to meet him.
Then I met Eminem,
and Dre came with him.
And it was just very controlled.
I tried to talk to him,
but he wouldn't look at me.
So if I'm looking at him
like this, he was there.
Sorry.
He just wouldn't look at me.
We're at each other, but he
would look the other way,
out my window.
And then, after
about 30 minutes--
I keep trying to get him
to talk-- he goes, I'm out.
I'm thinking, you can't be out.
You didn't say one thing.
And they go, he's out.
I go, wait a minute.
I said, come on.
I mean, you could animate.
You can say something.
And I think I made
him mad or something.
And he came back, kind of
pissed at me, but then talked.
And then he told
this whole story that
later became what "8 Mile" was.
So that was it.
That was the Eminem of it all.
SPEAKER 1: I love that story.
BRIAN GRAZER: And I love him.
He's a really
super professional.
I mean, he's an
amazing, gifted person.
SPEAKER 1: You said
something really interesting,
earlier, which is you kind of
started to understand leverage
and the laws of leverage.
And you used Warner
Bros., initially,
as a platform to meet all
these interesting people.
Can you kind of unpack that?
Because as a producer, you
probably use leverage a lot.
You're almost like an
entrepreneur for movies.
Can you unpack just the idea
of leverage and using that?
BRIAN GRAZER: Well, OK.
Sure, I think I can.
You have to have an idea.
This is so much like a startup.
The idea that you have, or
one that one would have,
doesn't have to be
what you end up doing.
It can just continue to change
form, change form, change form,
and change form.
There are two things
that are relevant.
One is to have the
spark of an idea,
so you have something
to say to somebody.
If you have nothing to say
to somebody, other than like,
hey, what are you doing--
I always feel like you have
to start with something.
That's like the gift
of the conversation.
If you have nothing to say,
even if you're super smart,
but nothing to say--
it doesn't go anywhere.
You can't build
nothing into something.
You have to build the germ
of something into something.
SPEAKER 1: And you've said that
when you reach out to people,
it can't be a generic
insight into them, as well.
It has to be something
kind of unique to you,
that you've recognized.
BRIAN GRAZER: Yeah, in these
conversations that I have,
it can't be Google-able.
If it's Google-able,
just Google it.
You have to ask a question
or have an insight or a gift.
I remember when I met Dre.
One of the first
times, I asked him
if he'd heard the musical
composition to Ernest Gold's
composition of Exodus.
I think it was like 1979.
It was really, really beautiful.
And I brought it up
not to be a wiseguy.
But I brought it up, because
when his music really
clicks or is on fire,
it's very melodic.
It's beautiful.
So he's got rap.
You know what it is.
He has a unique component,
that some of his songs,
when they really work,
they have beauty to them.
And they are melodic.
And I thought he would
really gain by hearing this.
He would dig it.
It's just like listening to
Hans Zimmer, or James Horn,
or something.
But this was a signature piece
that really stuck with me.
And he appreciated it, because
I had something to say.
Or just recently, I was at
your Google Sicily camp.
I get invited to go to
that, and I love it.
It's so amazing.
It's a privilege.
And last year, you guys
had Kevin Durant show.
And he was one of the speakers.
And I just know basketball
mostly through my kids.
Because these two
boys love basketball.
So they know who
Kevin Durant is.
But I barely know
who Kevin Durant is.
And he goes on
this friend's boat.
So we're now in Google Sicily.
We've done the
conference for the day.
Now, we go to the boat.
There's a boat.
A friend of mine's got a boat.
He's on the boat.
Kevin Durant shows up.
And when he leaves,
he says, hey.
I'd love to connect with
you when we get back.
And I'll be coming to LA.
I'm thinking, OK,
here's my number.
But I didn't think
he'd really follow up,
because what are the chances?
But he does follow up.
It's like weeks and weeks later.
He says, you want to get
together and have lunch?
And I'm at the
Beverly Hills Hotel.
We're playing the Clippers.
Sure, so we have lunch.
And I'm inventing stuff
to talk about, nervously.
And I do say, you
know, what I'd love
to do is like do
"Friday Night Lights,"
but in the world of basketball.
And he goes, oh, you know,
I grew up a little that way.
And he starts talking
about growing up in
and playing basketball
in a rec center.
It was this kind of very,
very, very lower-class rec
center outside of Maryland.
And then he described it very
quickly, which blew my mind.
He goes, yeah, we'd
play basketball.
And right next door, we shared
a wall with an old-age home.
And I thought, well,
that's pretty colorful.
I could see that,
because I always like
to know what things look like.
Always, always, always.
I won't hire a director, no
matter how smart or good--
I have to go, what
does it look like?
And then, they
describe the shot.
If the shot is whack, then
I just don't even do it.
Like if you're doing a comedy
and a director gives you
a wide shot, you know you're
talking with the wrong guy.
Because comedy is
a close-up medium.
So there's a lot of rules.
And you can not trick
people, but make
them feel comfortable to
tell you their true impulse.
Because their true impulse
is what they'll do.
A lot of people think,
oh, I'll talk him into it.
Or I'll negotiate my
point of view upon them.
Artists-- and it might
be true by engineers.
I don't know, but
artists do what
they say in the
first few minutes,
not what you tell them to.
So I met with Kevin,
did this thing,
and now, we're doing
a television show.
We're doing the "Friday
Night Lights" version
called "Swagger."
It's like the version
of basketball.
SPEAKER 1: That's very exciting.
BRIAN GRAZER: That's just sort
of starting from scratch, also.
SPEAKER 1: Do you have a
recent curiosity conversation?
You've been doing
these for two weeks.
Sorry, every two weeks,
rather, for a long, long time.
Do you have a recent one
that really affected you
and that you really
just enjoyed?
BRIAN GRAZER: I have.
I have one I can't
talk about very much.
I just went to Saudi Arabia
to do it, actually, last week.
SPEAKER 1: That's crazy.
BRIAN GRAZER: So not a lot
of people have been to Saudi.
I haven't been to Saudi.
And we think of Saudi
as a certain thing.
The beauty of these
curiosity conversations--
I've done at least 1,000
of them over the 30
years-- is that every
preconception that I have
has been wrong.
I have a 100% track record of
being wrong every single time.
Because whatever
you think it is,
wherever you think that
meeting is going to be,
or the party-- oh, that's
going to be a bummer.
It turns out to be great.
The person I hate
is going to vibe me.
He's not even there.
I mean, everything
is always wrong.
And so with Saudi, my
preconceptions were very wrong.
Now, some of the things in Saudi
that you do know are factual.
You know there's
the rights to women,
and decapitation,
and things like that.
But that's also on
a curve of changing.
That was super heavy,
going there and doing that.
SPEAKER 1: Most people
think of eye contact
as just normal kind of
etiquette in conversation.
Why is that so important to you?
You're writing a
new book about it.
BRIAN GRAZER: Oh, yeah.
So I wrote a book.
I wrote this book, right
here, "A Curious Mind."
And "A Curious
Mind" was really--
I was just going to write
notes on all my conversations
that I've had over the 30 years.
I had notes of the last 20.
But the first 10, I didn't.
And I thought, I better
do this while I still
have some motor skills.
And then somebody said,
well, you should just
do it as a book.
And then I thought
that was an ego trip.
And then someone
said, well, Graze--
some people call me Graze.
And then they go,
it's not an ego trip.
Everyone knows you
don't know anything.
I thought it would be
like one of those memoirs
where you're telling people how
to live your life or whatever,
blah, blah, blah.
Anyway, I did write this book.
And what it is, is it's
sort of two verticals.
One is like the
definition of curiosity
as a force and a super power.
And it is a synthesis of many
of these conversations I had.
And then that
synthesis intersects
with narrative storytelling.
Like one conversation I had--
I don't know if you
read this, but anyway, I
had a conversation with a
woman Veronica de Negri.
She explained to
me how she survived
torture, every single
day of her life in Chile.
And in that conversation,
what I learned was valuable
when I had problems trying to
figure out what "A Beautiful
Mind" should be and
from what perspective
it should be experienced,
like 20 years later.
So all the
conversations just serve
as sort of dots in a greater
constellation of dots
that you have faith
will someday connect.
And they do.
So I forgot the question.
SPEAKER 1: I think
you answered it.
BRIAN GRAZER: Did I?
OK.
SPEAKER 1: I want to get to the
audience Q&A. But real quick,
you know Hollywood
is changing so much.
And Google probably has a
hand in changing it, just
in terms of content
distribution.
What do you see
Hollywood looking
like in the next 30, 40 years?
BRIAN GRAZER: 30 or 40?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, or
whatever time scale
you think you can tell me about.
BRIAN GRAZER: I don't know.
Probably every artist that
can create a sustainable story
will be their own platform.
There'll be consolidation
of platforms.
But probably in the
future of 10 years,
more artists will have more
power over their own life.
SPEAKER 1: Got you.
Cool.
Does anyone--
BRIAN GRAZER: I don't
know-- positive.
SPEAKER 1: Does anybody have
questions, from the audience?
AUDIENCE: Thanks, I've
really appreciated
everything you've said so far.
So I worked in
film for 10 years.
And a lot of my friends are
aspiring writers, producers,
and actors.
I always think the ones who are
aspiring producers-- it just
seems like the most impossible
business to get into.
What advice would you have
for aspiring producers?
BRIAN GRAZER: Well, I'd probably
go back to having an idea.
Having some IP, whether it's
your own self-generated idea
or just any IP-- it
could be a short story.
It could be anything-- you have
to have something if you're
going to be a producer.
The definition of a
producer is somebody
that can generate
an idea, that can
see the vertical
line of the most
nascent stage of that idea,
until its final evolution
or conclusion.
So you have to be creatively
responsible and fiscally
responsible.
So that starting point
to its end vision
has to have a corresponding
part, financially.
Both things will change all
of the time, all of the--
but as I say this, it's
so much like a startup.
Isn't it?
Because you start off.
You're making a movie.
Let's say the good news
is you have this idea.
The studio wants to make it.
You go through this long process
of developing it, da da da da.
They're for sure going.
Cost is $50 million.
And then they go,
we're making it.
You're in.
And you feel like, wow, great.
They go, but we're
making it $30 million.
Then you have to
figure that out.
You have to cut scenes out.
You have to collapse the story.
Or you have to
convince them it's 40.
You know, it's multiple
different possibilities.
But you have to start
owning something.
AUDIENCE: So it seems
that, to me, you
said presence is kind of
the core of how you maintain
and grow your curiosity.
And I'm just curious about how
you use personal technology
in your life?
And I can see that
going in two ways.
One is a distraction,
but one is an enhancement
to your curiosity.
And how you kind of
control your behavior,
when it comes to personal
technology, what you use,
how much time you spend
in the offline world
versus the online world--
I'd just love to get
more context around what
that means in your life.
BRIAN GRAZER: Well, I
definitely use technology a lot.
And every day, I'm
doing some search binge.
Because it's fun for me.
But I have to start
with some idea.
And I also paint.
And I've painted for
about 20 years or so.
Starting is the hardest
thing, touching the canvas.
Whether it's an idea to
become a movie or television
show or a painting, for
me, Brian, knowing myself,
I can't execute perfection.
I don't approach anything
knowing Brian Grazer is
going to execute to perfection.
I try to have originality
as a differentiator.
So the original idea
is the one that I
will put the highest value on.
And it's the original idea that
that stress test is the one
that I'm interested in.
To be the greatest artisan is
just not interesting to me.
And I don't think I
could succeed at it.
But I think I can
have original ideas.
And like now, there's a lot
of evidence that proves that.
But that's where I put my value.
And then of course, I will
employ, through collaboration,
the ability to execute it to
the highest quality possible.
But I don't start like Chris
Nolan, who did "Dunkirk."
I don't start going, I
know I can execute this
to a level 100.
If I were to compare
to any artist--
I'm not this person, because
I'm not as great as this person,
but Andy Warhol just
did original shit.
That was it.
He wasn't like Gerhard
Richter, a scientist of art.
So that's how I look at it.
So I use your
Google all the time
to enrich original
ideas that I feel
like I'm touching, creating,
or being part of its creation.
So yeah.
It's an informant.
It informs all of that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BRIAN GRAZER: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Do you have a
process for these curiosity
conversations, or a standard
set of questions you ask,
or research you do
before going into them?
Because it's a skill and
an art to kind of extract
great stories from
people, as well.
So how do you go into
these conversations?
BRIAN GRAZER: You have
to get to the place.
Like get in flow, right?
Or in the zone, where you're
hoping for the very best date
of your lifetime.
And if you think about
your very best date,
you weren't constructing
stuff as it's going.
You're not thinking of what
are you going to say next.
You're really in
a state of flow,
and you're so present
that everything
is evolving in the most
sincere and authentic way.
I think just being as sincere
as possible, you can be funny.
And you can goof up,
like I do all the time.
But I think people feel
when other people are
a facsimile of authenticity.
There's a lot of agents
that I deal with,
I just feel like they're bots.
You know?
They go, hey, so
what's going on?
They come up with questions.
They somehow learned that
that was a method that
would create intimacy.
And I just don't
feel like it does.
Are you smiling?
Because it's true, right?
When you try to
methodologize it--
AUDIENCE: For me, as I
spoke to you earlier,
I've had some ideas.
And they're written down.
And they're not just ideas, but
the actual scripts are done.
What's the best way, or a
way, that you would recommend
getting them produced?
Like getting them done?
BRIAN GRAZER: OK.
This will be horrible.
What do you think?
Just take a guess, even
if it's the wrong guess.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
For me, like, submitting
to friends in the industry
that are producers, themselves,
or agents, managers.
I submit to contests
and stuff like that.
BRIAN GRAZER: OK, good.
But I'd augment that.
People don't really want
to drudge through shit.
So I think the best way, if that
would be the mechanics for you,
then you should know how to
say it in a really sexy way,
in like under a minute.
AUDIENCE: Got it.
Working on the pitch.
Is that what you're saying?
BRIAN GRAZER: Yeah, but work
on the sexiest, hookiest--
it could be 30 seconds, but
it forces the person you're
talking to to ask questions.
AUDIENCE: Got it.
BRIAN GRAZER:
People love to talk.
But they only like to talk if
they think you're interesting.
AUDIENCE: OK.
SPEAKER 1: Next question.
AUDIENCE: So along the
lines of that advice,
can you give the audience an
example of your sexiest pitch
that you've done?
SPEAKER 1: I was just
going to ask that.
BRIAN GRAZER:
Basically, my career
began while I was the law clerk.
And after Lew Wasserman
said, you better have ideas,
there was this book-- this
Leonard Maltin's "10,000 Titles
Of Movies Or TV."
And I realized,
for me, everything
started with a title or a word.
And there are certain words
that really wake you up,
like revenge.
There are certain words that are
like accelerators that wake you
up, and they make you
go, what does that mean,
or that have danger to them.
So I'd go through this book.
I'd get these words.
They then became titles
or the ignition point
of what my question would be.
I mean, "A Beautiful Mind."
I could do any of them.
You should ask me.
I can do to any of them.
I made three movies
all in a year
that were all because the studio
dared me to make a small budget
movie.
So I made the movie "Friday
Night Lights," "Blue Crush--"
it's like a girl empowerment
movie about three girls at surf
on the North shore of Oahu--
and then "8 Mile."
And they all began
with "did you know?"
I looked at it like this-- have
you ever watched 60 minutes?
It's been on for 30 years.
I thought to myself, if I had
to work for one of those guys,
like Dan Rather or whatever,
and Dan Rather goes,
he only has like a minute,
I'm a junior nobody.
I said to everybody that works
for me, including myself, I
have to pretend like I'm
working for Dan Rather.
And I got like
one minute to say,
did you know that this thing
is going on in central Africa,
in the Congo right now?
That duh duh duh.
You have to talk like that.
That would be how I do it, OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
and now into the valley
of disillusionment.
Do you think that could be a
medium for storytelling that's
viable?
Or do you think
it's best or not?
BRIAN GRAZER: Well, I liked your
question that's a conclusion.
I really like it, because
I feel similarly to you.
And I've sort of
been on the same--
I met the guy that created
VR, Jared something,
literally 25 years ago,
in northern California.
Anyway, I've been to
every one of those places,
Magic Leap, all that stuff.
I think it interrupts
emotionality.
And optimally, anything
that becomes cinematic
should ignite emotion.
And when it ignites emotion,
it becomes indelible.
And then, all of a sudden,
it becomes a memory
that you care about.
You care to tell others.
It affects you.
I think VR, so far
in my experience,
interrupts narrative
storytelling,
which is the map to emotion.
So I'd like it to
work, but I haven't
seen it yet work that way.
AUDIENCE: So I always got the
vibe that in Hollywood there
were tons of aspiring
actors and actresses
who are working minimum wage
jobs trying to "make it."
And probably the same thing
with screenwriters, I always
see a bunch of them in
Starbucks and so forth.
Are there any roles
in Hollywood that you
feel like there's actually
a shortage of people for?
Like if we had more of
this type of person,
more overall stuff
would get created.
BRIAN GRAZER: Anything other
than straight American, there's
less of.
There's too little of.
It And it's weird.
The movie business, which is
sort of posited or positioned
to be really liberal, I
found it's not very liberal,
actually.
It's very ethnocentric.
It's very judgmental.
It's kind of its own
hypocrite, in my opinion.
It lives in its own hypocrisy,
in that there's usually
only one--
You know, like Eddie
Murphy, I'll say.
Because I don't
want to say it's me.
Eddie Murphy said,
there's only--
because I made six movies
with Eddie Murphy--
room for one black, funny guy.
Or there's only room
for one fat, funny guy.
You know there was
Fatty Arbuckle.
Then there's this.
Then there's John Candy.
Then there's Chris Farley.
Hollywood doesn't have a lot
of elasticity, like that.
It should.
That's my new quest of what
I'm going to try to do.
That's why I like to
go to the Middle East.
And so I go to Latin America.
I like to be on the ground.
When you're on the ground,
people are not data.
You get to see and feel them.
And then, you don't treat them,
or you don't make "The Great
Wall" with that Matt Damon.
Do you know what I mean?
It's just like they
just thought, OK, these
are the requirements.
I'll make "The Great Wall."
The Chinese will love it, bang.
Put in Matt Damon.
It was just like you can't
weld things into things.
Incidentally, I make a
lot of mistakes in movies.
I don't make that particular
mistake, but as you know,
my movies and television
are fallible, too.
I have a good movie
coming out, by the way,
that you guys are handling.
It's called "The
Spy That Dumped Me."
I'm not trying to just promote
stuff, but it's pretty hip.
It's a super funny,
girl power movie.
It stars Kate McKinnon
and Mila Kunis.
And I know it's cool and shot
really well, like great action,
but it's funny.
These chicks are really funny.
And you guys are working on it.
SPEAKER 1: That was a
sexy pitch, right there.
BRIAN GRAZER: There it goes.
Oh, yeah.
There you go.
Thank you.
Come back, right?
All right, I think I got to--
I'm sure you guys
all have to go.
Thank you for being so polite,
and nice, and everything.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you so much,
Brian Grazer, for coming.
[APPLAUSE]